hi everyone that is Professor M the
science and today I want to discuss icon
values and eigenvectors of operators
this is another one of our videos on
rigorous quantum mechanics operators are
the mathematical objects that allow us
to represent physical observables in
quantum mechanics when we measure a
physical observable the only possible
outcome of this measurement is one of
the eigenvalues of the Associated
operator and after we have measured that
property the state of the system is the
corresponding eigen state of the
operator this means that to learn more
about quantum mechanics we first need to
learn about eigenvalues and eigenvectors
so let's go postulate 3 of quantum
mechanics is the first of a series of
postulates that describe the process of
measuring you will remember from
postulate 2 that the physical quantity
is represented by an operator which we
call an observable then postulate 3
tells us that the result of a
measurement is one of the eigenvalues of
the Associated operator this means that
to understand measurement in quantum
mechanics the very first thing we have
to learn about or the eigenvalues and as
we will see the eigenstates of an
operator this is precisely what I want
to discuss in this video to start we
need to remember that an operator a is a
mathematical object that acts on state
Phi and the level is not a state Phi
Prime before moving on if you need a
refresher about operators check the
video in the description we now come to
the definition of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of an operator a we
consider the action of a on a special
cat side such that the only way in which
a changes side is by scaling it by a
constant and we obtain lambda up side
lambda is the scaling constant and in
general it is a complex number now I
can't emphasize enough how important the
states I and scalars lambda are in
quantum mechanics the equation here is
called the eigenvalue equation of the
operator a we call psi the eigen state
or eigen ket or eigen vector of the
operator a these terms mean exactly the
same in quantum mechanics and we call
lambda the eigenvalue of a the prefix
eigen that we use for all these
quantities comes from German and it
means proper or characteristic this is
because the eigen vectors of an operator
are those special
directions in the vector space which the
operator doesn't change a final
definition that we need is that the set
of eigenvalues lambda is called the
spectrum of the operator a before moving
on to learn more about eigenvalues and
eigenstates i want to say something
about notation the eigenvalue equation
is very often written like this in
quantum mechanics remember that the
label the cat has no intrinsic minim it
simply allows us to identify the
particular ket that we're talking about
when talking about again cats it is very
convenient to label them by their
corresponding eigen value and this is
what I have written in this equation the
lambda here is the eigen value of a and
the ket here is the corresponding eigen
ket in the rest of the video I will use
the form up here but both forms are used
very often in quantum mechanics so you
will see me using the one down here in
many other videos in the rest of the
video I want to do two things first I
want to look at some important
properties of eigenvalues and
eigenstates and second I want to discuss
how we can calculate the eigenvalues and
eigen state of a given operator so let's
start with properties the first property
is that the eigenstates are only defined
up to a constant to see this consider an
eigenstate psi of an operator a with
eigenvalue lambda then construct a new
cat psy prime equal to alpha beside
where alpha is a constant how does a act
on this new ket we first write a acting
on Alpha Psi then we can move a through
alpha because a is a linear operator and
we get this then we can use the fact
that psy is an eigenstate of a and we
get alpha lambda beside as alpha AMSOIL
scalars we can make change their order
to obtain this new eigenvalue equation
for a in terms of psy prime so what does
this mean this is exactly the same
eigenvalue equation we have here website
so indeed any multiple of psy is also an
eigenstate of a with the same eigenvalue
what this also means is that all an
eigenstate is telling us about is a
direction in state space and then any
state along that direction whatever its
length is an eigenstate of the operator
with the same eigenvalue to remove this
freedom about the length of eigenstates
we will always work in terms of
normalized eigen states what this means
is that we will choose the
alpha that will make the scalar product
of Sai with itself equal to 1 eigen
values and eigen vectors are of course
not exclusive to operators in state
space you can be find them for operators
in other vector spaces and they are
useful in many different areas but
because state space is a complex vector
space that is one important extra
subtlety compared to real vector spaces
which has to do with a global face
factor even after choosing alpha to make
the length of an eigenstate equal to one
we still have some extra freedom in the
eigenstate imagine sy is normalized and
then built a new state sy prime by
multiplying side by a global phase e to
the I theta this global phase is just a
constant subsite prime is also a
negative state of a with the same
eigenvalue let's see what the length of
Y prime is we start with the bracket
here when I use the definition of sy
prime and to do this remember that to
build-a-bra from a cat we need to take
the complex conjugate of any constants
so we get e to the minus I theta here
the Exponential's combine to give one so
we get side side which is 1 this means
that the length of C prime is also 1 so
even after normalizing an eigen state in
state space we still have an extra
degree of freedom coming from a global
phase factor these MB with is in fact
true for any cat not just for eigen
ket's as in this last derivation we
haven't really used the fact that sy
happens to be an eigen ket of a so what
can we say about this extra degree of
freedom physical systems have
well-defined properties so this freedom
strongly suggests that whatever quantum
mechanics tells us about nature it will
be independent of multiplying a ket by a
global face once you finish watching all
the videos on the postulates of quantum
mechanics you will see how this is
indeed true the next property I want to
discuss is the generous e of eigenvalues
we say that the eigenvalue is non
degenerate if there is a single
eigenstate associated with that
eigenvalue we of course now know that
what we mean by that is up to a constant
alpha by contrast we say that an
eigenvalue is the generate if there is
more than 1 linearly independent eigen
state with that eigenvalue these of
color are just names but as you can
imagine we only give name
two important things the generate
eigenvalues bring in many subtleties in
quantum mechanics so we will constantly
make the distinction what I want to do
next is to look at some of the
mathematical consequences of the
generous e because they are crucial to
understand many ideas in quantum
mechanics that I discussed in other
videos imagine we have an eigenvalue
that is n fold to generate we write a
PSI i equals lambda psy I where I runs
from 1 to N and it labels the n linearly
independent eigen states that share the
same eigenvalue lambda now imagine that
I build a new cat site as an arbitrary
linear superposition of these
eigenstates as shown here what I want to
feel next is that psy is also an
eigenstate of a with the same eigenvalue
to see this let's consider a sigh then
we replace psy by its definition at the
summer website i item states then we can
use the fact that a is a linear operator
to move it inside and get this
expression here we can then use the
eigenvalue equation for a here to write
this in terms of lambda then we can take
lambda outside the sun because it
doesn't depend on i and finally we
obtain lambda son so what is this
telling us any linear superposition of
eigenstates in the degenerate n-fold
subspace is also an eigenstate with the
same eigenvalue now that we have talked
about some of the properties of
eigenvalues and eigenstates the final
question that remains is how do we find
them I want to start with a specific
example which I will call a simple case
the identity operator the identity
operator acts on a cat file and leaves
it invariant doing this in the language
of an eigenvalue equation we see that
any state Phi is in fact an eigenstate
of the identity operator with eigenvalue
1 this also means that the eigenstate of
the identity operator are infinitely
degenerate as they all share the same
eigenvalue so what have we just done we
have figured out the eigenstates and
eigenvalues of an operator by simply
looking at how this operator acts on
States this is something that you can do
with the identity operator just like
with it and also with some other
operators like the
action operator or the parity operator
however for an arbitrary operator it is
typically not possible to figure out the
eigenvalues and eigenstates simply by
inspection of how the operator acts so
what we need is a more general approach
to finding eigenvalues and eigenvectors
what I will do here is to make some
general mathematical statements about
how to find the solutions and what their
properties are I will keep the
discussion abstract to give you an idea
of what we're doing from a mathematical
point of view but the best way to learn
about this is by doing at the end of the
video I will explicitly calculate the
eigenvalues an eigenstate of an operator
as an example but in fact I do that for
many other operators which are relevant
to quantum mechanics in many other of my
videos so for more example just have a
look at those to start we consider a
basis u that is orthonormal and we write
the eigenvalue equation in the u basis
you'll remember from the video on
representations that to do this all we
have to do is to project both sides of
the equation onto the basis States here
next we insert the identity operator
after the a operator in the left hand
side then we write the resolution of the
identity in the U basis as shown here we
can take the sum over J to the beginning
because the first two terms don't
explicitly depend on J and doing this we
obtain this expression we then see that
this term here is the representation of
the operator a in the U basis and these
two terms are the representation of the
eigenstates I in that basis as a
reminder this here are the explicit
representations of the state and the
operator we can move the right
site to the other site and obtain this
final expression here to write this
final line I have introduced the
Kronecker Delta IJ and you should
convince yourself that it is correct an
easy way to see this is that the Delta
IJ is the representation of the identity
operator just like the a IJ is the
representation of the a operator to make
progress let's copy the final expression
we got for lambda and see this equation
is equivalent to the original eigenvalue
equation up here but now it is written
in the U representation eigenvalues are
the same in any representation because
the original equation is independent of
the representation the physical meaning
of the eigenvectors is also the same in
any representation but when we write
them down mathematically that form can
change and here we have them represented
in the U basis in terms of the C
coefficients so finding the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors now becomes finding the
lambda and C in this equation what we
have here is a linear and homogeneous
system of equations for the unknowns
lambda M C we can also view this as a
matrix equation where a and 1 are the
matrices associated with the operators a
and 1 and C is the column vector
associated with the eigen state in
quantum mechanics we call this the
matrix formulation of the theory and I
have a video describing this matrix
formulation so check it out if you want
to learn more about it in this language
finding the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
becomes a mathematical exercise called
matrix diagonalization which is
something that many of you will probably
have encountered in other areas what I
want to do is to briefly discuss the
mathematical features of matrix
idolization and I have linked a few
external references in the description
if you want a more in-depth refresher
about this for an N dimensional state
space we have n equations for n unknowns
and mathematically the solution to such
a system of equations is found by
setting the determinant of the
coefficients to 0 this is called the
characteristic equation and solving it
allows us to find the eigenvalues lambda
what can we say about these eigenvalues
the characteristic equation is an nth
order polynomial equation for lambda and
such an equation has n solutions
typically called its roots which in this
context are the eigenvalues for a
general operator a these M solutions can
be real or imaginary numbers
and they can be unique in which case we
call them simple roots or some of them
can be repeated in which case we call
them multiple roots now I've said many
things but stop here for a moment
and make sure you remember this because
we're going to use it in the next slide
once we have found the eigenvalues what
can we say about the eigenvectors let's
first rewrite the eigenvalue equation in
principle we can replace the roots
lambda we found by solving the
characteristic equation one at a time
into the eigenvalue equation to find the
corresponding eigenvectors see now as we
saw in the previous slide we can have
two types of root those that appear only
once and those that are repeated for
unique roots we'll find one eigenvector
however who repeated roots or in other
words roots that have a certain
multiplicity P the situation is more
complex in general we expect to find P
eigenvectors associated with those
spirited roots if the p eigenvectors are
all linearly independent and it is true
for all roots then that means that we
will have a total of n linearly
independent eigenvectors in our n
dimensional state space and we will be
able to diagonalize the matrix however
if we find that some of those p
eigenvectors are repeated then we will
not have enough linearly independent
states and we will not be able to
diagonalize the matrix for our purposes
having such repeated eigenvectors could
be a real problem
however in quantum mechanics were mostly
interested in two specific types of
operators hermitian operators and
unitary operators luckily for us in
hermitian and unitary operators we never
encounter this situation we can always
find n linearly independent eigenvectors
that allow us to diagonalize the
operator okay so this probably all
sounds rather abstract again I have
links to external references in the
description if you want to learn more
about this but from a practical point of
view all we really need to do quantum
mechanics is to get enough practice in
diagonalizing matrices and it
essentially amounts to following a
recipe this is why I want to finish
looking at an explicit mathematical
example of finding the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a matrix
in the matrix formulation of quantum
mechanics let's consider an operator a
given by this matrix which I just made
up and the states I given by this column
vector we want to find the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of the operator a and
the eigenvalue equation can be written
in Dirac notation as shown here or also
in the matrix formulation of quantum
mechanics like this we start by
constructing the characteristic equation
we then write out the determinant
explicitly we then evaluate the
determinant which for a two-by-two
matrix means multiplying the main
diagonal and then subtracting the
product of the off diagonal terms
simplify this expression we see that
indeed for a two dimensional state space
we get a second-order polynomial
equation and this equation should give
us two roots we can very easily find the
roots or eigenvalues which in this case
are plus I and minus I the next step is
to find the eigen vectors let's start
with the eigen vector corresponding to
plus I the eigenvalue equation then
becomes this we can calculate the matrix
product and we obtain this equation
comparing the first entry on both sides
gives us minus c2 equals i c1 and
comparing the second entry gives c1
equals IC to these two equations in fact
contain the same information we can
multiply the second one by I and then
operating through we find that we end up
with the first equation this means we
only need to focus on one of the two
equations say the first one a solution
to this equation is c1 equals I which
then gives c2 equals one and we can then
construct the eigen state corresponding
to eigenvalue plus i we know that any
multiple of this eigen state is also a
valid eigenstate and in general we want
to work with normalized eigen states so
we normalize the state to obtain this
remember that you can still multiply
this normalized eigen vector by a global
phase which is essentially a number of
magnitude 1 and for example multiplying
this by AI corresponding to theta equals
PI over 2 gives this which in quantum
mechanics represents the exact same
state as the original one you should
repeat the same exercise with the other
eigen value and you will find that the
eigen vector in that case is this when
you can
your solution to mine remember that they
could differ by a global face okay this
was a rather long video but we've done
diagonalizing matrices is an essential
tool because it allows us to find the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of
operators these quantities are essential
in quantum mechanics for example they
play a key role when we measure the
physical state of a system this means
that we need to get as much practice as
we can antagonize matrices and if you
want another example check out the
videos on the poly matrices if you liked
the video or would like to send me
suggestions for future videos please
subscribe